Hausa go in this lets parapa enjoy this
episode oh sure
oh well you're at the flavor either
they're crawling in I need help I need
back up back up
yes we're on our way I'm on my way Felix
with my son beyond me what a cackle okay
where is me all right
okay night Manny that's that's pretty
good I'd where's it's he's that feeling
that's a black slammy kill the black
zombie well she came right for me it's
not ray says she came for me wait who is
that I'm out of here I got your back
Marcus on you I gotta go
holy friends with twins behind you mark
behind ya haha take help help house
hello
looks like oh my god you're my hero or
welcome I know there's one way you could
repay me the answer is yes
oh let's go to those tunnels over there
oh my goodness
behind me mark behind me save me you
could you can try you got a sledgehammer
ah my prince
thank you oh yeah you showed me you
[ __ ] shot in the edge okay what why I
didn't mean to till I see my friend die
anytime now makes it be great he's
touching me only mark can touch me I
mean no get off him you not mark I press
right and right click that's me I've
come back from the dead I still love you
even though I'm a zombie professing my
love to you how do i roar oh he's like
you is that you alone I bet I'm I love
you
I stopped makeup baby oh oh can you kill
them I think I can connect sobbing oh
yeah oh I hate you
I'm so sorry it's like I'm dead don't
worry about that mark i right-clicked
and that apparently charges in attacks
and when I let go it just killed use ice
I didn't mean to do it
oh okay I see I forgive you Wow
hey let's go on this constant hey you
are oh hi it's not moving it's not
moving mark you're too fast
shut up you cute goddamn hey let me rip
off my arm maybe make me light it up
don't worry I'll help you
oh thank you thank you just ow look at
me look at me
oh well jeez yeah look at me it's so
beautiful they're not looking at me it's
like your uncle a avoid look at me look
at me my I can look at it so beautiful I
can't oh you're going to kill me you're
going how do you kill what is killed a
little just like that Oh
what I do hey I'm not I'm not one of
them oh you're trapped now you're
trapped now I gotta let them [ __ ] are
you guys twenty wait I see flashlights
over there can I call you guys on my
iPad phone I can beep you can like be
able actually air my thumb is taking
this statement who did go ahead and take
your equipment in because you're gonna
die anyway I shot a zombie behind you I
wasn't shooting at anything else don't
worry
oh and another sexy officer man oh my
spend a day ken are you the bond 100 my
mama Mia
oh yeah I did that I did that a high
imputes go back behind that alley house
for you you need it you need help move
out
let's go to the alley
well she going to party huh yeah yeah oh
[ __ ] how do I remove this thing that's
fee and smack it
I'm not smacking anything unless it's
Ken's but how can it work at kitchen
wait
can there be zombies in here without us
knowing about it what make you say booze
there's not in here at the moment but
some might come I know there's a savage
always said it was Ken sorry sorry wait
who killed the pretty blonde oh no no
it's finished about Jessica that's so
good
I never saw it coming do it I worked
late
I think it was eight I think anybody
said that someone was starting with an e
I'm a bad stomp you but I'm not gonna
see I'm not gonna say how you know the
guy that killed me said that he killed
me before you guys started play them
somehow
why maybe probably killing can you go in
there please
we should probably kill imputes I don't
even know what's going on see no matter
what okay [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] that room I'm
gonna go to somewhere else
Shh what what are you you were not
supposed to say this I don't you should
have shut up dad now mine isn't working
I think it's not working
all right shoot him that one okay [ __ ]
that's what you [ __ ] get yeah I can't
wait to the next round of start that was
fine I'm just gonna do it the whole time
so you have a deal I can I swear I did I
get a kick spin in this game cuz it's
stupid
I press sorry this episode was a little
short we had a lot of problem with the
gameplay and stuff like that
I'm actually going to Sweden tomorrow so
I'm so hope you both understand wait
leave it like you enjoyed watching hit
the sky khon birthday I'll see you in
the next one
I never do it I feel my son became a hot